the deadly shooting of three Georgia
teenagers is being investigated as a
potential stand your ground case
investigators say the three boys were
wearing masks and fired first during an
attempted robbery Monday morning
national correspondent Jericka Duncan is
outside the Rockdale County Sheriff's
Office in Conyers Georgia east of
Atlanta jerrika what do we know about
this confrontation well still very
little at this hour authorities have not
released the name of the teenagers or
the alleged shooter the sheriff here
says that he doesn't believe this was a
racially motivated shooting because he
says everyone involved is black now two
of the suspects were reportedly brothers
all range in age from 15 to 16 years old
he kept his hand on his wound and he
said I'm dying Brian Jenkins lives two
houses away from where the shooting
occurred that voice I will always
remember this young man perhaps died on
my lawn he says he heard gunshots and
found one of the teenagers bleeding out
officials say around 4 a.m. Monday the
three teenage boys approached the home
with plans to rob it one of the
teenagers allegedly fired the first shot
at three people on the lawn before the
homeowner returned fire signs on the
property clearly state that trespassers
may be shot good possibly be a stranger
Brown case they did discover masks on
the young man again that that rolls our
suspicion police say one of the
teenagers died before police arrived
the other two died at the hospital
neighbors say the man who shot the teens
lives with his mother I know him very
well he's a very good man he felt as
though he had no recourse but to defend
himself and that's exactly what happened
none of the residents in that
neighborhood were injured obviously this
is still an ongoing investigation no
charges have been filed yet Gail tarika
thank you very much a lot of questions
there